Joel, we love your honest take on things.
I mean, we hung on your every word
for how many years with "The Soup,"
as well as your multiple television shows and movies.
But we like to hear your honest opinion.
So if you're open to it, we'd like
to take the Joel Poll.
(funky music)
(audience applauds)
Everything is very disturbing about that.
That's my, I should have called the "Joel McHale Show"
on Netflix "The Joel Poll."
Maybe it would still be on.
That's terrifying.
All right, well, okay.
Comment on this.
How do you feel about skinny jeans?
The kids say they're out!
(sighs) Hey you kids, just so you know it.
skinny jeans will never be out until you
pry them off my cold dead
very compressed calves, okay?
Still in! I've invested way too much.
Okay, hugging was trending on Twitter the other day.
Are hugs gross now?
Okay, hugs have always been not gross and gross.
They've always, there's a spectrum of hug.
And if you let the hug go even a second
or two too long, then it's gross.
Yeah, I think it's time for just the birth
of a new salutation.
Okay, it's the final season
of "Keeping up with the Kardashians."
Any predictions on what we might see
in the final season?
Is that a television show?
Yes, exactly.
Funny enough, on your old alma mater, E!
Oh, I always called it, "Eh."
(laughs)
Hey, I'm so sorry for the Kardashians.
'Cause you know, I can't believe the show got canceled.
I thought it was gonna go the distance.
Yeah. It's like 20,000 years.
I think it's been on.
Early on, we used to make fun of them on "The Soup"
and Kris Kardashian would call every week
and be like, "He made fun of us again."
And so it was then the President of E!
would call Ted Harbert would be,
it was like we had thrown a baseball
into their yard and then they're like,
"This is mine!"
And so Ted would always be like,
"Hey man can you kinda lay off 'em this week?"
And I would be like, "Sure!"
And it was like, "Two weeks from now is fine."
And so that, and then I got to know Kris
a little bit and she's lovely.
And, but I always, that was early on.
That was back in 2006, Drew.
I know so many people who know and work with them
and like the rumors are just nice upon nice upon nice.
Yeah, and that, I think that is their secret weapon
for their longevity is that they're super kind
and their crew, I think their crew would die for them.
So I think it's they made that thing a real family.
And obviously, the popularity.
It was almost as popular as "The Soup"
but still, they got close.
I loved "The Soup" so much.
I never missed an episode.
It's like the best show ever.
I'm like a talk show host now.
Would you have any advice for me, Joel?
The problem is you've been on
a short period of time, but you're really good at it.
So, which, I mean, obviously that's the thing is
that you've kept this thing conversational
and kind of, and very cool.
You're not, you can tell the vibe is relaxed
and so you're cool and calm.
So that lends itself to professionalism,
which we rarely went after.
That's, it's hard to pull a clip.
You know what?
I think when we launched
you probably could have pulled a lot of clips.
Oh, well.
I came out of the gate.
I think we have
a time machine.
Yeah, I came out of the gate real, real strong.
I mean, I was like hosting a talk show
with no, not a lot of guests and no audience.
And I was like, I know I'm just gonna go for it.
And it was like the third quarter of 2020,
like we were all nuts.
It was a time, it was a weird time to come out
acting like everything was normal.
So I just kinda went with it.
Do you think that when an audience returns,
it will, you'll be like, feel like it's
all of a sudden new again?
Like all of a sudden, you're hosting a different type
of show or do you think you'd be like,
"Ah, I've had so many, so many reps that I'll be fine."
I think that the crew and I really like bounce
off each other and we sort of made a pact early
on to just like be noisy and ourselves,
and kind of egg each other on,
because you do need that energy.
And I would always hear people giggling
and egging you on on "The Soup."
It's like, if you do this to avoid,
you're going to go crazy
because nobody can work without any response.
Like when we were starting,
other than our crew and family,
I had no idea if anything was funny
or landing, like that's what an audience
can give you is some barometer and indication.
So thank God for the crew,
because they have been that North Star for me,
and the energy in the room.
That's great.
And so I'm very lucky
And I think other people will just be an extra addition to.
Yeah, no, I can hear your crew laughing
and that's really cool.
That's the thing.
They don't give it up.
So if they do laugh, you know they like it.
I, we, the first year of "The Soup," nobody watched.
So the only people laughing were the crew, and the writers,
and the producers, so that when people started watching,
I never changed the mindset that I'm like,
oh, I'm still just trying to make my friends laugh.
And I think that I kept that
throughout the 12 years that we did it.
So, and that really helped me
because I didn't, again, I didn't know
if it was funny or not.
I was constantly questioning it.
I think that was the best piece of advice
that if we do keep the intimacy of this show,
and we're trying to make each other laugh
rather than like pandering to the outside,
maybe that is a secret recipe.
'Cause "The Soup" was crushed.
It was like the first of its kind.
And I think there's been many copies since,
and it's just you are such an original
and it was a magical recipe.
So I'm really gonna take that advice to heart,
and I will be happy and we wanted to launch a show
that we were enjoying and having a good time at,
and felt thankful to be at regardless.
So yeah, I think we'll keep hat recipe, Joel.
Thank you.
I just wish I had made money off those other shows
but I didn't.
You got a laugh! See?
Yes!
(applauds) Joel McHale, I'm so happy to see you
and hang out and thank you for that brilliant advice.
And I'm just so happy for your movie "Happily"
which is so fun and delicious,
and out in theaters and on demand right now.
And give my very best to your family.
(upbeat music)